questi questi erano i cavalieri dello
zodiaco
tutto sotto
forte l'euro
non sono peso di nuovissimo challenge
dobbiamo indovinare i loghi più non
indoviniamo più possiamo andare avanti e
prendere i vari badge sì iniziamo con
questo facile ovviamente anche voi
potete giocare con noi scrivono i
giudici che vedete ora potete scriverlo
oppure potete dirlo a voce alta prima
che noi lo diciamo e poi segnatevi
quanti punti avete fatto se volete alla
fine del video scriveteci nei commenti
quanti punti avete fatto chef altri
luoghi avete indovinato pronti i bravi
ma
allora iniziamo con quello facile facile
allora il primo luogo è facilissimo
scrivetelo se sapete qual è non lo
sapete è proprio questo gioco qua ed ero
block scriverlo nella sas per vanità
scritto se l'egitto si fa passare
anche questo va bene perché non lo è i
vari commenti o ditelo voi impegnatevi
punti grazie apple
però
prossimo lo
hai
scritto
dai questo è facile anche
grazie roberto anche questo massimo ei
perché mi ha coperto quello che ho
scritto
nike no ei due vitale
sono rimasto bloccato al mcdonald's
ma non mi fa passare non so perchè
perchè non l'hai scritto bene
sicuramente scritto male ok abbiamo
ricopriremo orientale allora questo
forse è un po più difficile ma non ho
mai ti conosce e mike roma crowe soft
ritorno a microsof
da questa pagina web dai lo sappiamo e
dei rebus red bull
tra
questi c'è anche scritto un po
aperto e questo ancora più semplice dei
e dee pepsi
è bravo entriamo dai questo non potete
non conosce il 4 mi ricordo di quella
che state usando perché è questo video
youtube
pagine instagram è qualche luogo più
difficile questo non lo conosco ad
esempio che cos'è
dai sapete qual è quel dare questo
[Applauso]
roma
e questo mi fa
tristezza
questo forse più difficile è si è più
americano che si è mai avete quale
questa dai anche questo è molto facile
e questo ps post scriptum
che qui come rocky ex gioco vede di
scrivere le cose di
questo giocatore ha scritto wifi
bellissimo wifi bravo effettivamente si
assomiglia tantissimo al logo del wifi
sì è vero non aspettando che noi abbiamo
la risposta giusta dai aiutiamolo avete
o ti fai anche questo e facilità
e questo lo sapete questo forte un po
più difficile ed è wikipedia
se la bravo è bravo
invece per loghi pazzo adesso andiamo a
medio allora dài oppure difficile e
vediamo non so se medio però e 5 notti
da freddy cioè finance travis e io non
mi ricordino di personaggi che quindi
forse è meglio trovare oggi è facile
anime invece difficile ma qualcosa mi
dice che qua per i cartoni animati in
italy non lista o no ci sarà da ridere
allora noi l'abbiamo fatta in fretta
nascone siamo tutti allora pokémon dai
non è così difficile
dai vediamo però non ci questo perché
vitale
si schierano i corrieri della giustizia
ha appoggiato l'herbe
questo gioco diventerà troppo divertente
proprio perché evitare non
ci sono destinati bicchiere
questi sono i debiti
ai bambini
quando si parla di energetica ea
quasi come ricordo il nome
ti do un indizio del
desk no chi è
dragon ball e lo sapevo non ce l'avevo
in testa non è possibile che vi dragon
ball non ho mai visto tra l'altro bollo
scritto con loro non ci credo guarda
l'italia
adesso passiamo dai questa questione
solo individuo
io non so chi e lo sto benissimo e
alludono era prima a ridere che intorno
alla classe perché nel guerriero
chi è
vicino siracusa
io conosco
dai quello grosseto e famosissimo dai ti
do un indizio vita con la n
nicola di bari
non lo conosco di ho detto di no limit
la te.ma
no naruto
e ha fatta ti scrivo come si scrive
naruto non sono d'aiuto si va dai questo
quale e famosi capitan harlock il to
die questo era sampei
sofferto la vecchissima prova che
mostrino però centra lo stesso con il
mare con l'acqua da inizia con la o o no
an ora
col
portiere trap ha ordinato kateri moto
morini conigli rifarà
onirici saputo dai e ti dicono è formata
da due parole in inglese ok
te l'ho detto già varie volte questo
anime qual è la prima parola è uan
wan wide area
tue parole in inglese one direction però
quali sono i cantanti non c'entra
va bene dai questo lo scrivo io sono non
ci parliamo ormai da one piece one piece
monusco
ok il problema è che queste non sono
sicuro di quale dio
ce l'ho visto spesso ma non so quale sia
il nome peccato però che nel gioco non
ci danno degli indizi e chiuso uno per
capire almeno il problema è che è vitale
non saprà mai qual è quello non lo saprà
mai e io non sono sicura tickle sia
forse era già vediamo sicuramente voi lo
saprete shadow hunter forse no non è un
po come si chiama e firmo slater anche
se adesso direi però che non conosciamo
fullmetal alchemist
dopo questo video deve scrivere full wet
ad attaccare
dopo questo video andremo a vederci
fullmetal alchemist perché non è
possibile che non lo conosciamo
a staccare
non ci questo
hai sbagliato a scrivere lo aspetta lo
scrivo io
al che mesto
o pugliesi non ne abbiamo cantata questa
o no e questi chi sono è troppo
difficile
ma da ieri questa è
sempre il personaggio di un videogioco
no non è lei boh
ok ragazzi
non riusciamo ad andare avanti perché
non abbiamo idea di cosa stia questo
grattacielo nei commenti lo sapete si
così per il prossimo video andiamo
avanti con cui il team ora torniamo
nella lobby e andiamo cosa c'entriamo
parte saliamo lui e non supermario
youtuber
youtuber ma facciamo youtube erano
americani però è vero c'è tipo questo
non ho idea dovrebbe quindi difficile
rapper non li conosciamo lo stesso
racconto infernale
non lo so questi forse sono personaggi
cattivi
però non so chi sia ma sappiamo su
magari troviamo qualcosa di più
interessante ok anche italiano
allora abbiamo animali facili
minecraft minecraft kakà però bros e
meme
animali
animali e è fin troppo facile se vediamo
ancora più sopra cosa c'è qualcos'altro
celebrità sport bandiere
come ricordano neanche uno adori può che
va dai questa facile dai e allora io e
te come mi dovete nella piccola di 2
minuti scrivono si era scritto bene dai
dai questo è facile questo è dai come si
chiama per
nome
famiglia qui non me lo ricordo ma di
aver bravo dai o sono fuori allenamento
più allora è l'evoluzione di charman der
sar izzard bravo dai scrivi lovisari non
ne ho la più pallida idea
vediamo
ciari zardo io lo scriverei così è
venuto
dai questo è
un orgoglio
tortellino
[Musica]
ecco allora era
perché ha dato tutto la turtle
fortuna torto torto non me lo ricordo
allora il primo e quarto lo scritto del
starter poi
l'evoluzione che è
quella dai questo te lo dico io perché
non ci arriverai mai si chiama black
sea dai ho perso io questo come allora
come questo era allora se non sbaglio
dovrebbe essere l'evoluzione di retata
però mi sono sbagliato
se non al top o piazza se non sbaglio
allora questo lo trovo perfetto può
diventare questo è ciò che questo lo so
perché ci avevo avuto per tanto tempo e
si chiama come se lei avuto 6 quando
giocavamo era il mio persone del mio
preferito che poteva dovreste sapere il
nome è mai più dimentico le cose non sai
come si chiama questo era
da e farà un nome se lo dici io sono
sicuro come lo ricordo mamma
era un nome solo di terra mi ricordo che
era di terra e di acqua
il quale sta andando in crisi
dove
brandita tratta da
20 valenzana nuovo nome di venus our
bratta venosa non ci credono questo non
me lo ricordavo
musa ora è che hai detto che quando
sentito te lo saresti ricordato dai
blues o se si scrive così si scrive così
allora no questo no questo è facile
questo punto dai l'evoluzione di magic
harp ti guardi magic harp treat rientri
allora magica atto si trasforma in
questo coso bellissimo che indo però non
so come si chiama dai di come si chiama
se condotta secondo me però questo è
proprio sicuro se magica
scarto proprio
scarto cerchiamo
soprascarpe sulla logica allora di
cataratta che si chiama non lo so come
si chiama
e questa challenge diventa vitale cambia
i nomi di pokémon magi scarpe e magi
scart regole è però magis carte
non ha funzionato
vabbè dai lo metto agli altrimenti non
ci muoviamo più vari questo è gary dott
ma uno come fa sapere che ieri dos e il
personaggio scritto in quel nome in quel
nome
quello di
agosto è uno dei mentre questa miu too
human scusa
mio tono ragazzi si prospetta ho
sbagliato non ci posso credere cosa mi
lucana che indovina qualcosa come si
scrive non lo so ci sei quasi ci sei
quasi min cherie dovetti scritto bene
veramente così non lo so come si scrive
lo so you tube così youtube
guardate come vita è
vitale a film come altri
mai detto giusto né vuoto youtube no
senza il tool più
[Musica]
così
fatta da è questo è youtube
[Applauso]
to
see non ci credo
da allora questa è l'evoluzione di
pillon che non ho la più pallida idea di
come si chiama non è l'evoluzione di
pisano anche se ne spieghi potrebbe
pirlo miniati giocatori è strano avuti
sei ritornato il nome di p g 8 picciotto
era non è più g8 perché questo è blu
vedi aima termica di riprova form on
rari ci sono tre pokémon leggendari
sono tre pokemon uccello leggendari uno
era esatto
stop loss a 1
subito con la figuraccia per ora come si
chiamava quello di fuoco non mi ricordo
questa dovrebbe essere dato fuoco però
aspettano mi ricorda qualcosa
vediamo
nome lo tocco grey con l'altro contrada
cordialità questo dovrebbe essere arti
uno mi sembra
che noi da tokyo
un bellissimo nome se avete visti sul
gameplay dei poche ma noi gli abbiamo
dato un altro nome hurtig una tra queste
è vero troppo divertente
allora il problema che quasi uno dei
nuovi pokémon e non lo conosce come si
chiama vedrai che dice un nobile e
soprattutto come si chiama a
sparare un nome dico
branco l'hai tu
stia bene
allora secondo me tipo from stone
troviamo rong rong stone mick foxton
hite è così lo chiamerebbero così
borraccia
sigg li paghi
quello dietro e g dopo che il nonno che
questo da riconosciuto e quello rosa di
tupac anche quando si trasforma diventa
jekyll buffone e perché il grande e più
grande
ragazzo
purtroppo siamo fermati siamo
fermi qui scriveteci nei commenti il
nome di questo pokémon così possiamo
procedere su questo video raggiunge i 7
mila mi piace e continueremo lo
strafalcione di milano da parte mia
quando lasciato mi piace perché è troppo
divertente questo gioco questo che
impregna è stato troppo divertente
scusate non mi piace e ora vi lasciamo
come se li faccio qui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video estate su
quello che preferite regolato a tutti